hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
gonna be checking out the trailer for
the point break remake is there a point
in making a remake to this no not at all
but a lot of people are saying that i
should check this trailer out but before
i do i just wanted to let you guys know
i'm gonna be on schmoes know tonight
that's right the live show going on at
around 7 o'clock the show starts I think
at 6:30 Tyrone's going on at that time
so make sure to tune in where tyrone and
i reactors assembling for the schmoes
know where i might blow one of the
schmoes anyway
let's watch this this wouldn't know
Keanu Reeves and Patrick Swayze just as
part of with me the first one so good
there are some who do not fear death for
they're more afraid of not really living
what kind of people are we dealing with
here set of perps with a very unusual
skillset
I need a theory it's pretty cool
I agree so why not deploy your chute
above the jungle escape like a normal
person because I'm thinking these aren't
normal people sure you're athletes
I believe that like me the people behind
these robberies are extreme athletes
using their skills to disrupt the
international financial markets
and they don't care who gets killed in
the process
they call me buddy
whoa
there's a few billion dollars of gold
down there you're gonna steal it
no we're going to liberate it
oh you think your brothers are you show
me inside you are
criminal masterminds
they just kids partying away their life
we can get these guys I just need more
time
sweet [ __ ] thong colliders man
bori do you have any idea how many
people you've killed
how many laws you've broken it doesn't
matter the only well the mahdis is
gravity look look real look very real
okay I think I'm a little one over sure
the trailer really conveys that this is
gonna be a dark tale the way it looks I
mean it doesn't look like just tonally
it's dark it looks like it's shot with
some type of Dart kind of green shade
going on I mean they didn't really
change the story much I mean a lot of
movies have done this kind of story
detective goes in gets lost in the
criminal world is confused about who
they are but it doesn't look like it's a
really compelling character picture I'm
a little worried that this film is gonna
get caught up too much in the points
they're trying to convey the messages or
whatever about economy financial [ __ ] I
don't know exactly what but something
political I'm watching this film I'm
like it's kind of like Fast & Furious
franchise now one point they're all
sitting around a table you know and like
you've seen the original it's a it's
it's about family I mean when people see
a trailer like this the main reason I'm
gonna go watch it is for the cool action
sequences not necessarily for like it's
awesome unique story what I like about
it kind of reminds you of the new
Mission Impossible trailer like it's
really big and scope there's a lot of
cool action sequences but I think it
might be the same music too and the way
it like the fades go a whole tone of it
it's like an action movie but it's
really dark and serious I like the way
it's at least being promoted I don't
know it's gonna be that way but
something tells me it might take itself
too seriously but then again it's just a
trail these are just like you know after
watching so many [ __ ] trailers and
then you watch a movie and you spend
your time just breaking down trailers
and studying them you do start to notice
like what the film's might do wrong
immediately from a trailer but that's
not to say that I'm right I'm saying
that that's just what I'm predicting man
these people gonna go watch this is for
the action sequences and I think for the
action sequences they look really cool
for the most part when they're
parachuting and the money's falling
everywhere that looked real like I'm
sure
was real in some way the gliders looked
real even at the end when he jumps off
the cliff I'm sure that's not real but
that looked real I just feel like that
it's not going to be so overblown with
CGI at times but I think it's going to
be cool to watch actual action sequences
with legit stuntmen in there
so yeah I'll probably wait for another
trailer before deciding to watch this
doesn't NAB kind of in the middle point
anyway guys thanks for telling me that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can also Facebook Instagram Twitter
where if we get enough followers we can
get product placement for things such as
stress balls stress balls are great you
know if you ever are having a hard time
jacking off because you're too stressed
and you can't do it yeah squeeze this
stress ball and before you know it your
balls were filled with enough just you
know fill the milk jar stress balls hey
soos jimenez Trejo he is the son of
Jesus Christ and Danny Trejo
hey Ryan can I get a shout-out and how
do you feel that you're gonna be on the
schmoes know podcast hey soos here's
your shout-out my Jesus friend how do I
feel that I'm gonna be in the schmoes
know podcast well I'll tell you how I'm
gonna be on the schmoes know podcast I
think I'm gonna be amazing
I think Tyrone and I are gonna compare
Dixie who has a bigger one obviously
it's gonna be me they provide you
complimentary water to drink during the
podcast and I think Jesus over here you
can turn it into wine for us and at one
point Mark Ellis is gonna die that's
just our prediction and you'll be there
Jesus to resurrect him from the dead
sorry about that Jesus I know you get a
lot of Jesus jokes cuz her name is Jesus
I blame your parents for that but
hopefully everything goes well for you
and your future you don't get me to
photo too much for having that name may
Christ be with you